mean in the end so you exactly yeah  bishop f4 hugo king g1 and king g6 the  final move is rookie six that wraps up  the game  exactly and the bishop is lost  so yeah very nice control by magnus of  koziak queen d7  bishop f5 that's it basically knights  designs  because if you don't uh don't take the  queen then you get checkmated if you  take then you are just technically lost  but even bishop f5 was a very important  detail because i just realized on the  last move otherwise the queen is  attacked and the bishop on g6 is  attacked the queen doesn't have a great  square to defend the bishop but now with  everything under control um it is just  an exchange up attack on the king and  adivan knows it's all over he resigns  magnus carlton wins wow peter seven  decisive games yeah well i mean i don't  have all the boards on my screen but  yeah what i see everybody wins and there  is only one christopher you against  lebanon  i